une
occupante illégale pour
pour moi en fait je suis locataire
encore aujourd'hui
puisqu'il y a des un appel
en novembre
j'ai demandé des délais et aujourd'hui
je suis là pour m'exprimer alors donc
s'il y a un appel en novembre ce qui
veut dire que donc on aura passé la
tribunal donc vous allez pouvoir passer
jusqu'au 15 mars dans la dans la maison
aujourd'hui Nadia pourquoi vous n'avez
pas quitté le logement puisque Pierre et
Marie se voulait le récupérer pourquoi
ce que vous voulez pour l'instant
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui fait que Nadia
n'a pas voulu sortir concrètement Cyril
dans le cadre de ce dossier il faut bien
comprendre plusieurs choses alors je
vais me permettre de répondre à votre
question juste après vous avez bien
compris ma cliente est perturbée par
cette histoire elle est dans une folie
médiatique
c'est très perturbant pour elle et ça
lui cause aujourd'hui véritablement
beaucoup de soucis vous travaillez à
Nadia
vous avez une fille deux enfants deux
enfants une fille qui les deux habitent
avec vous non d'accord vous avez votre
fille qui habite avec vous oui tout à
fait c'est ça
une fois qu'on a dit ça on va essayer
d'avancer aujourd'hui on n'est pas venu
se cacher si on voulait se cacher on
serait pas venu sur votre plateau on
serait pas venu sur l'émission la plus
populaire de France finalement d'accord
on est venu prendre nos responsabilités
discuter finalement c'est un peu
compliqué pour moi aussi parce que je
suis dans un dossier vous allez me
l'accorder assez facilement qui est un
peu casse gueule puisque j'allais dire
il est beaucoup plus simple de venir
aujourd'hui dépend défendre les gars que
de venir aux côtés de Nadia et
contrairement à ce que beaucoup peuvent
penser c'est avec honneur aujourd'hui
que je porte sa parole
alors on va vous laisser par là je vais
vous dire ce que j'en pense parce que
c'est vrai que mon avis Pierre et Marie
aussi qui sont qui sont très atteints on
va en parler dans un instant
sur le principe ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que Nadia est locataire d'un
logement il ne s'agit pas d'un squat
Alain bail ce bail était signé en 2017
ce bike a été signé en 2017 elle donc
elle habite ce logement depuis 5 ans
maintenant contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu sur les réseaux je suis dans
diverses émissions il n'y a pas de
problème à la base de loyer impayés et
d'ailleurs la déjà vous a produit une
pièce aujourd'hui que vous avez
peut-être montré dans lequel l'agence de
location d'accord qui est en réalité le
seul interlocuteur de Nadia ça veut dire
que Nadia les hippocarciens ne les
connaît pas elle ne les a jamais
rencontré le bail a été fait avec une
agence immobilière les loyers sont payés
auprès d'agence immobilière les
quittances sont livrés par l'agence
immobilière les époux Garcia finalement
les fois physiquement il y a 48 heures
sur les médias non quand ils nous ont
dit qu'elle n'avait pas payé l'eau
également qu'est-ce que c'est c'est vrai
cette histoire ou pas alors il y a aussi
une pièce qu'elle vous a produit
aujourd'hui que vous allez peut-être
montrer vous allez voir un mélange
peut-être c'est la régie
vous connaissez bien C8 merci Maître on
va voir alors ils l'ont la régie bon bah
il sait pas alors c'est quoi la pièce
alors c'est un mail que Nadia envoie fin
2020 à l'agence immobilière à Marseille
en disant voici la photo du compteur
merci de bien vouloir m'envoyer la
facture afin que je puisse régler cette
facture d'accord donc c'est une action
positive de sa part elle n'est pas
sollicitée pour payer cette facture elle
va justement vers l'interlocuteur vers
l'agence immobilière pour demander de la
payer donc finalement l'agence
immobilière ne lui répond jamais à ce
sujet là donc aujourd'hui c'est assez
facile de venir sur des plateaux télé en
disant finalement je suis retraité bien
évidemment qu'on comprend cette
pollution mais juste mettre ils veulent
récupérer leur maison ils ont fait
apparemment toutes les démarches
nécessaires pour la récupérer pourquoi
en fait qu'est-ce qui fait que Nadia ne
peut pas quitter le logement
actuellement parce que Cyril je pense
que c'est un échappe à personne on est
en France et en France à l'état de droit
d'accord l'état de droit
[Musique]
peut-être que le régime va peut-être le
produire ça va mettre
la régie on est vous êtes toujours là
vous êtes rentré à la maison maintenez
vous le cul maniez-vous le cul s'il vous
plaît je vais m'énerver allez-y vous
allez voir c'est une lettre de l'agent
immobilier puisque finalement lorsque le
congé est envoyé et ça c'est quelque
chose que personne a dit et vous avez
tous les éléments qui permettent de
corroborer ce que j'explique aujourd'hui
le congé lui envoyer il y a pas de
difficulté initialement sur son congé
voilà vous l'avez ah voilà bravo en tout
cas vous êtes plus franchement vous avez
plus de d'autorité que moi je vous
adresser le 6 mai 2020 un courrier pour
vous informer que votre bail ne serait
pas renouvelé car les propriétaires
souhaitent récupérer leur appartement
pour il va très bien effectivement en
dessous vous avez contacté par téléphone
le 28 décembre 2021 pour vous annoncer
que les propriétaires souhaitaient
annuler le congé qui vous avait été
donné voilà donc on est si vous voulez
en deux temps on a d'abord initialement
un congé qui est donné et puis une fois
que le congé est donné d'accord il y a
l'agence immobilière qui va contacter
Nadia pour lui indiquer que finalement
les propriétaires vont rester au
Portugal et que ils ne donneront pas su
donc congés on est en décembre 2020
alors le courrier que vous montrez est
un courrier de vous devriez 2021 ça veut
dire que plus de deux mois se sont
passés entre
l'annonce comme quoi il ne reprenait pas
leur logement et l'annonce finalement
que pour des décisions par rapport au
covid et une problématique pour rester
opportun c'était compliqué vous le voyez
c'est en février 2020 alors justement
alors aujourd'hui on parle de Pierre et
Marie Nadia vous comprenez que ils sont
dans une situation catastrophique ou pas
Pierre et Marie vous le voyez est-ce que
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça vous fait
moi là je vous rappelle à votre cœur
Nadia moi j'ai pas envie que vous soyez
aussi dans la merde voilà je vous le dis
voilà on a pas envie que personne soit
n'est pas n'est pas de logement
aujourd'hui bon on dit compte que c'est
leur projet de toute une vie ils veulent
récupérer leur maison ils ont ils ont
des gros problèmes de santé sachez
qu'ils sont vraiment au bout de leur vie
je sais que vous ne leur avez jamais
parlé et on va voir votre réponse et je
vous le dis ils sont ils sont au
coulisses
voilà ils sont là je sais que voilà vous
le saviez pas mais Pierre et Marie ils
sont là vous vous direz ce que vous
voudrez Nadia on fera ce que vous
voudrez puisque vous avez bien accepté
de meilleur sur le plateau et mettre
aussi si vous voulez leur parler ou pas
si vous voulez qui viennent après vous
sortir et que il vous répondent mais on
a envie de régler l'affaire ce soir
aujourd'hui vous voulez rester jusqu'en
novembre c'est ça
ce que vous avez demandé
aujourd'hui
l'audio que vous avez passé hier
effectivement vous l'avez clairement
repris elle n'en peut plus donc
finalement vous a clairement dit au
téléphone j'en peux plus je vais prendre
quatre affaires un album photo et puis
je vais quitter ce logement j'en peux
plus il y a deux dossiers dans le
dossier excusez-moi d'être précis mais
finalement je pense que c'est important
il y a le spectre moral il y a le
spectre juridique le spectre juridique
aujourd'hui il y a un double degré de
réduction il y a un appel qui a été
formé une audience qui est prévue en
novembre 2022 donc effectivement vous
l'avez dit à juste titre si finalement
on attend cette audience c'est un peu le
serpent qui se prend là
et on va l'accuser finalement de faire
jouer un peu les gens envie de savoir ce
que veut dire Nadia qu'est-ce que vous
voulez voilà dites-nous et puis on va
essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire moi
je veux que tout cela cesse autour de
moi puisque votre fille elle paye des
mots modifie on le sait vous aussi ça
vous l'affaire et c'est extrêmement
médiatique je vois tous les jours votre
nom au top tweet Nadia donc c'est vrai
que voilà ça doit pas être facile
qu'est-ce que vous voulez aujourd'hui
ce que je veux depuis le départ en fait
c'était que l'agence tout simplement en
fait
en fait ils m'ont fait confiance
ces personnes là vous comprenez moi je
ne les connaissais pas et quand j'ai
regardé en fait le reportage je n'aimais
je n'ai même pas mis le sang j'ai dit oh
les j'ai vraiment dit ça j'ai dit les
pauvres oh j'ai des parents des
personnes âgées mon père qui a 84 ans ma
mère aussi ils ont travaillé toute leur
vie son propriétaire j'ai dit mais c'est
dégueulasse qu'il faut que je disais
vous avez raison ce que je veux dire
c'est que Nadia ne les a jamais vu elle
les a découvert à l'antenne dans touche
pas mon poste et dans les autres
émissions dans lesquelles ils sont
passés Pierre et Marie donc vous quand
vous l'avez vu et moi que vous me disiez
ça Nadia franchement ça me soulage et je
suis tellement content de vous entendre
dire ça vous êtes dit les pauvres ça
peut être mes parents ça peut être mes
grands-parents et j'ai dit les voir
comme ça dans un camping-car ils ont des
problèmes de santé on voit Maryse elle
prend des du Prozac elle est vraiment
elle est extrêmement fatiguée on sait
que Pierre il sort d'un cancer
douloureux d'où vous entendre dire ça
déjà ça vraiment ça je pense que ça
touche tous les téléspectateurs en fait
tu n'avais pas mis le son je regardais
et quand j'ai mis le sang carcia ça me
parlait Marcel 16e les photos mais c'est
de moi dans ton parle et pour les
problèmes de santé je n'étais pas du
tout au courant je ne suis au courant je
ne connaissez pas et en fait c'est passé
par une agence un moment j'ai voulu un
moment c'est ce que j'ai dit à mon fils
tu sais j'ai envie de les voir tu sais
je sais pas il y a peut-être leur fille
s'il habitait au Pen je vais chercher je
vais leur parler pour dire qu'en fin de
compte c'est vraiment un quiproquo et
que c'est par rapport à l'agence moi en
fait je ne fonctionnais qu'avec l'agent
j'ai en fait j'ai payé des frais
d'agence j'ai toujours payé mes loyers
ils étaient prélevés j'ai juste réévoqué
au moins d'août tout simplement en fait
tout simplement le loyer à partir d'où
elle travaille elle a une fille ce que
quand je vous entends ce soir je vous
dis je suis heureux j'ai envie qu'on
trouve une solution sur pour vous parce
que j'ai envie aussi j'ai pas envie
voilà de vous laisser voilà dans la
panade aussi j'ai envie qu'on trouve une
solution bien entendu pour Pierre et
Marie